the best way to see how Auto amela
vision and natural language work is
through live demos let's start with
vision to show you Auto ml vision we'll
look at a model I've built for
predicting the species of a leaf given
an image the data for this is source
from the leaf snap data set and our
model is trained on images of ten
different types of leaves here in the
auto ml vision UI is where I gather and
label all of the images that will be
used to train my model I can upload them
directly to the UI and I only need ten
images per label to start training the
best part about Auto ml is that I don't
need to write any of the model code to
train this I can simply press the train
button to train my model this particular
model took exactly one hour to train
when training completes I can take a
look at metrics to evaluate accuracy
this is what's called the confusion
matrix it tells us the percentage of
images for each label that our model is
able to classify correctly ideally we'll
see a strong diagonal down the top left
since this means our model classified a
high percentage of the images in our
test set correctly and we can click on
any cell to see the specific images
where our model got confused finally the
most important part of this process is
generating predictions on images our
model hasn't seen before let's try our
model out by generating predictions on
two images of leaves as someone who's
not a plant expert I'd probably classify
both of these as leaves or if we're
being very technical green leaves let's
see what our model says
turns out these both belonged to
different species and our model has
predicted both varieties correctly with
over 96% confidence once we have a
trained model Auto ml gives us access to
a custom REST API endpoint to make
predictions if I add more images and
train a new version of my model I only
need to change the model ID in my API
requests I am incredibly excited about
Auto ml because it gives anyone the
tools to build custom models regardless
of their machine learning expertise you
might even say that auto ml vision is
turning over a new leaf in the way we
build image classification models and
although I've shown plant species
classification here you could easily
build a model in any other domain we've
seen our alpha users build Auto ml
vision models for identifying damaged
products before they're shipped
classifying catalog specific images and
identifying points in time like stages
of construction but what about other
kinds of information like text documents
or news articles with Auto ml natural
language it's just as easy to build a
custom model to make sense of written
content take donorschoose.org for
example a non-profit that receives
hundreds of thousands of proposals each
year for classroom projects in need of
funding they currently rely on a team of
volunteers to manually screen each
submission so they published a dataset
to Kaggle in hopes that a community of
machine learning experts could build
them an automated solution let's see if
auto ml natural language can help
similar to auto ml vision here I can
look at all of the examples in my
dataset and their corresponding label
the text inputs to my to our model our
need statements from the teachers
detailing the materials they need for
their classroom each need request has an
Associated category to help direct the
teacher's request to a relevant donor
the label is used to train the model
have been assigned manually by
volunteers once the model is trained
it'll be able to predict the category of
new requests automatically to see how
our model performs on new text that
hasn't been categorized yet we'll take
the following needs statement as an
example my students need aquarium
lighting for our environmental clownfish
aquaculture project
DonorsChoose needs to assign the
category lab equipment to this request
which isn't completely obvious from the
text itself let's try it out on our
train model we can see that our model
was able to correctly classify this as
lab equipment with 98% confidence like
Auto ml vision I now have access to a
custom model that I can use to generate
predictions on new text with one API
request that's really all there is to it
without writing any model code you can
build custom machine learning models
that can accurately recognize your own
images understand the contents of your
documents and even translate your jargon
authentically they're ready to use
immediately accessible through Google
Cloud and they scale automatically to
meet your needs